tour du burger quiz alors c'est un
événement très attendu et j'ai eu
aujourd'hui 50 appels de personnes qui
disent vous avez vu hanouna aurait dû le
prendre sur ces mythes alors déjà je
suis pas le patron de sce vite déjà
s'appuyer pour commencer massy et non
non je vais vous expliquer toute
l'histoire
le recours le retour du burger quiz donc
c'est un événement très attendu alain
chabat on avait d'ailleurs fait la
promotion d'un l'émission village médias
sur europe 1 et lors de son passage pour
le savoir a là un chameau et moi on se
connaît assez bien puisque j'étais son
stagiaire à l'époque de comédie et voilà
donc je les croise et très souvent et il
avait assuré qu'il n'était pas venu me
voir pour discuter d'un retour du burger
quiz
il explique avoir été voir canal je vous
l'expliquais vraiment ce qui s'est passé
et si le burger quiz a failli être sur
ces 8 ou par garde pourquoi ça ne s'est
pas fait sur ces 8 ou sur canal+ on la
propose évidemment un canal en premier
c'était c'est burger quiz est né à canal
donc c'est quand même la moindre des
choses et ça les a pas intéressé alors
je ne sais pas exactement pourquoi on a
pas on n'a pas été voir cyril hanouna
comme je le lis à droite et à gauche on
a été voir canal
cyril d'ailleurs vous voulez le
reprendre il ya quelques années je crois
au tour de 2012 2013
à l'époque c'était pas du tout
d'actualité
alors c'est vrai alain chabat il ya
quelques années pour le reprendre sur
sur ses bits ou sur canal+ alors je vous
dis la vérité alors alain avait pas la
bonne info parce que les producteurs
jérôme revon et stéphane gâteau sont
venus me voir ici pour me le proposer
sur ces vides
on avait donc même l'intention de le
mettre à 18 heures je vous le dis sur
ces 8 à un moment peut-être en pendant
les vacances pour faire tourner entre
c'est que de la télé et le burger quiz
on avait même il m'a mêmes pros composé
l'animateur on ça devait peut-être
bertrand chamerois qui ont animé le
burger quiz j'étais je vous le dis la
vérité sur bertrand chamerois je leur ai
dit j'adore bertrand mais je trouve un
peu vert pour présenter un gros barnum
comme ça j'avais proposé un autre
animateur
j'avais proposé je vous le dis j'ai
proposé camille combal voilà pour
représenter et j'avais dit mais l'idéal
ce serait qu alain chabat revienne et
qu'il en fasse quelques numéros
donc on était hyper chaud on avait même
fait les budgets puisque j adore et pour
preuve pourquoi j'ai ramené comme dans
les émissions politiques le directeur
général
2au donc la boîte de production qui va
tout vous expliquer comme ça il n'y a
plus d'ambiguïté on est juste à la voilà
donc on avait le dossier je vous ai dit
mais on est passé on va le dire on est
passé à côté de burger quiz
voilà ça a cartonné hier dont voulait le
faire voilà donc on avait le dossier
avant 2017 novembre 2010 cette voie là
on devait le faire vérifier toutes
étoiles à on avait on avait tous et donc
qu'est ce qui s'est passé mon lionel on
a tout envoyé la chaîne s'est réunie
l'on est un peu de temps nous on était
d'accord camille combal tulle a raconté
et puis pas de nouvelles de la part de
la chaîne ils sont allés voir tf1 ce qui
est normal comme surproduction et ma
chaussure jeu c'est vrai et on leur a
dit allez voir peut-être tmc tf1
peut-être que ça va les intéresser je
pense que c'est c'est bien pour eux ils
sont allés les voir et tmc tf1 ont pris
le projet mais en tout cas on peut vous
assurer voilà qu'on nous avait proposé
le burger quiz et deuxième chose on
n'était pas hyper chaud sur ces 8 je
vous le dis nous allons reprendre de
vieilles marques alors il ya des gens
qui disent oui mais sur ces huit ya le
grand frère illias avis de recherche qui
va revenir mais voilà on a déjà beaucoup
de nouvelles dans cette mare qui
reviennent lenval ans et strike on va
lancer une nouvelle marque qui s'appelle
la scoumoune
on a envie aussi de tenter de nouvelles
choses donc bravo à tmc et nt1 pour le
succès mais c'est génial
juste je vous le dis un moment aussi ses
huit m'a dit oui cyril on aimerait bien
que ce soit toi qui l'animent gély et
mec je ne peux pas faire de l'antenne de
11h à minuit
donc voilà donc j'ai refusé la
présentation du burger j'ai dit voilà on
prend vraiment et on le prenait 6 alain
chabat faisait voilà les 40 premiers
numéros parce que je pense que la vraie
force de burgers tout cela n'a pas trop
de discorde hier soir on va pas se
mentir demain vous mettez n'importe quel
autre animateur chancy ge avait présenté
- burger quiz sur ces mythes joly on
aurait fait 1100 villes alain chabat il
fait 2 millions
donc voilà c'est alain chabat il est
extrêmement populaire et je pense que
c'est le meilleur là dedans il faut que
vous sachiez quelque chose c'est que
quand même alain avait passé la main aux
autres animateurs à l'époque de canal+
ils avaient tous à diviser l'audience
par deux et assure voilà alain chabat
très populaire on l'a vu et donc bravo à
thème c'est nous c'est tout ce qu'on a
dit elle très convaincant à la voilà
on aurait bien voulu que ce soit sur
celui ci n'est pas de nice-cannes
directeur général à deux magnifiques
[Applaudissements]